BRET?
>> Bret: CLAUDIA COWAN LIVE
IN CHICO TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY BE CLOSE
TO TURNING IN HIS HOMEWORK
ESSENTIALLY TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSELOR.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE HAS
COMPLETED A LIST OF
QUESTIONS FROM INVESTIGATORS
AND HE SAYS HE DID IT
HIMSELF.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON
REPORTS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLAIMS HE HAS PERSONALLY
FINISHED ANSWERING SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER'S
QUESTIONS.
>> THEY WERE MY ANSWERS.
I DON'T KNOW LAWYERS FOR
THAT YOU NEED LAWYERS TO GO
OVER SOME OF THE ANSWERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS HEARING
HE IS ENDING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO
END SOON.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE JUST
FINE.
YOU KNOW WHY IT'S GOING TO
BE FINE?
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
>> PRESIDENT TWEETED OF
MUELLER AND HIS TEAM THEY
ARE SCREAMING AND SHOUTING
AT PEOPLE THREATENING THEM
TO COME UP WITH THE ANSWERS
THEY WANT.
THEY ARE A DISGRACE TO OUR
NATION AND DON'T CARE HOW
MANY LIVES THEY RUIN.
WHEN ASKED THIS AFTERNOON
WHAT SPECIFICALLY PROMPTED
THAT OUTBURST, THE PRESIDENT
SAYS IT'S JUST THE
CONTINUATION OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WHICH HE SAID
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
MATTHEW WHITAKER NOW
OVERSEES THAT PROBE.
BEFORE TAKING THAT JOB, HE
WAS CRITICAL OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, SOME CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS ARE PUSHING THE
WHITE HOUSE TO SOON SUBMIT
AN ATTORNEY GENERAL NOMINEE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS INVOLVING
MR. WHITCHER AND THE ACTING
AG COULD BE ELIMINATED IF WE
HAD A NOMINEE AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE WHITE
HOUSE IS STARTING TO LOOK
INTO THAT AND BUT I DON'T
HAVE ANY -- AS I TOLD YOU
THIS MORNING, I DON'T HAVE
ANY INDICATION OF TIME LINE
OR HOT CANDIDATES ARE.
>> SENATOR CORNYN SUSPECTS
THE COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
THE INVESTIGATION WILL BE
FRONT AND CENTER DURING THE
HEARING CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
ONCE THE PRESIDENT SUBMITS
HIS WRITTEN ANSWERS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
INDICTMENTS OR EVIDENCE
AGAINST THOSE CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT OR INFORMATION
DAMAGING ENOUGH DEMOCRATS
PUSH IMPEACHMENT THROUGH THE
HOUSE.
THOUGH IF MUELLER'S REPORT
FALL SHORT OF MORE
INDICTMENTS OR STRONG
INDICATIONS OF COLLUSION,
HOUSE DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE
TO WEIGH WHETHER
IMPEOPLEMENT IS WORTH THE
RISK.
GIVEN THE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THE LAST
POLITICAL IMPEACHMENT.
A SOURCE TELLS FOX NEWS THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT SUBMIT HIS
ANSWERS TODAY IN SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
ALSO THIS AFTERNOON AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED IS HE NOMINATING
ANDREW WHEELER AS HIS
ADMINISTRATOR TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY.